in england we will remove all remaining
domestic restrictions a lot of us are
leading much more normal lives perhaps
most normal now for the last couple of
years during the pandemic but the latest
results from the office for national
statistics show kovid really hasn't gone
away
[Music]
in the week up to march the 12th three
and a quarter million people across the
uk had the disease that's about 4.8
percent of the population and it is an
upward trend that's the concern for many
people
if you look what's happening since the
omicron peaked in the beginning of
january when about 6.8 percent of the
population had the disease since then
cases have been coming down to about 3.8
at the end of february but since then
they've been going up
there are many different reasons you can
look at the lifting of plan b at the end
of january you can look at the prime
minister's statement that we would be
living with kovid in future and that has
led to a big change in behavior people
are more relaxed the wearing a face mask
the use of lateral flows social
distancing all these things have been
decreasing in recent weeks and people
are mixing more with others both
socially and and at work and that of
course gives an opportunity for the
virus to spread
there will be new variants and it is
very possible
that those will be worse than omicron
the big difference is that we're now
dealing with a slightly different virus
for the first few months of this year
omicron has been dominant it's now
called ba 0.1 but that's now being
overtaken by a very similar virus called
ba 0.2
the two of them are so similar that
they're called sister variants or
sub-variants and they are both just as
sensitive to the vaccine they both cause
the same very mild disease
but the point is that ba2 is 1.4 times
more infectious and that gives it the
edge over the original omicron virus and
allows it to spread much more quickly uh
there are sort of so-called sub-variants
of omicron and we're not concerned about
any of those at this important time
there has been some talk of this delta
cron variant it's a hybrid if you like
of two different viruses the original
delta and omicron that have come
together probably in one person who's
been infected with both viruses at the
same time that has been an issue in
france but the health secretary sergey
javid has said there have only been a
handful of cases here in the uk and at
the moment there's no clear evidence
that it's any more of a threat than
omicron itself and of course delta
was effectively dealt with by the
vaccine
the situation in hong kong is certainly
a concern but it's very different to
what we're dealing with here in the uk
in hong kong vaccination rates of the
elderly are much lower it's only about
one in three
people over the age of 80
have actually had the vaccine so the
most vulnerable are still unprotected
against the virus which is spreading
around there hong kong disappointingly
no problem with vaccine supply
for well over a year
had not achieved coverage of our most
vulnerable group the second point is
that in hong kong they use the chinese
sinovac vaccine and there has been a
great deal of concern about just how
good that is
and the chinese are understood to be
looking at mrna vaccines developing
their own because those have really
stood out in this pandemic as the best
way of protecting people against the
rapidly evolving virus we need to find
our own way out of this epidemic it has
outgrown our capacity it's unlikely that
here in the uk we would suddenly be
developing a situation the dreadful
situation that they're encountering in
hong kong where where some say that
they're actually beginning to run out of
coffins because deaths are so high
hospital admissions in the uk are also
rising and many people are concerned
about that the rise in hospital
admissions aligns very precisely with
the rise in cases both started to take
off
at the end of february now in previous
waves you would have had a lag between
people getting infected and people
getting so ill that they needed
emergency treatment this time that
hasn't happened they're both happening
at the same time and that suggests the
rise in hospital admissions is actually
due to people coming into hospital with
the virus but are being treated for
other conditions they're not coming in
for treatment for covid itself it's an
important distinction so although
hospitals will be disrupted by the rise
in emissions it doesn't mean that we're
going backwards and that as a nation
we're suffering more severe disease
quite firmly the answer is no this is a
very different situation the vaccine is
still highly effective the immunity is
being topped up as the virus spreads
and the two together are in a very
effective way of controlling the spread
of the virus it's very likely that as
the weather warms up and we spend more
time outside that that too will have an
effect on transmission but that doesn't
mean omicron has gone away it may well
return in the autumn as the effect of
the boosters does begin to wear off most
important thing you can do is get your
booster we've already heard that the
government is planning some kind of
booster campaign in the autumn months
just to make sure that we are topped up
and that we can go into the winter
hopefully better prepared than we have
been in recent years